lorsque la morale décline
et que les hommes bons ne font rien, le mal prospère,
une société qui ne veut pas apprendre du
passé
est condamnée,
nous ne devons jamais oublier notre histoire,
nous ne devons plus jamais
abaisser notre dieu,
vous deviendrez l'homme le plus
puissant du pays, je
crois que  Lorsqu'un homme fait
partie de ce bureau, il doit
se comporter de manière à éliminer la
moindre possibilité de critique
quant à sa conduite. M. Tolson, j'ai besoin de
quelqu'un en qui je peux avoir confiance. Je veux que tu sois
mon homme numéro deux. Tu comprends que j'ai besoin de
toi.
imaginez si chaque citoyen de ce pays
était identifiable de manière unique par le
motif sur ses doigts
imaginez avec quelle rapidité nous pourrions trouver s'ils
ont commis un crime
vous vous souvenez de l'incendie que nous avons déclenché sur sa
femme Mme Roosevelt vous faites une copie pour
moi s'il vous plaît
est-ce légal parfois vous  besoin de contourner
un peu les règles afin d'assurer la
sécurité de votre pays,
veuillez me laisser les transcriptions ici,
n'hésitez pas et partagez-les avec votre
frère, M. Kennedy, faites-lui savoir que
j'ai une copie du mien,
le président a peur de toute l'
admiration qu'il contient  le monde ne peut pas remplir la
place où va l'amour, nous sommes des pécheurs
et nous avons toléré l'anarchie dans le pays
et de tels groupes aux proportions diaboliques
et le sang est sur votre main secteur
quelles sont vos qualifications exactes pour
votre poste de direction dans ce
bureau mes qualifications  monsieur, je ne
sais plus à qui je peux faire confiance, je vois
à travers vous, vous êtes un
horrible petit homme effrayé, sans cœur,
ne travaillez pas comme une petite fleur, sois
forte, oui, maman,
il est temps que cette génération apprenne la
différence entre le méchant
et le héros,
même génial  les hommes peuvent être corrompus